Verkligen var nogande att utvärdera chef för fötstidhud.
Det finns där av en anledning.
Absolut inte tro att man är osynlig i den rollen.
Det är tufft alltså.
Det är chefskapet och ledarskapet framåt, det kommer bli problem.
Alla kan inte, alla får inte, alla vill inte.
Make Sweden Stronger Men är det så, nu gick vi in, du ska få berätta lite om dig själv, men jag bara hoppar in här lite.
Det är rätt sjukt att ni, vad sa du, omsökt en 160 miljoner.
Jag är ju chanobilgenerationen, jag kan inte ta, du vet, vem du är typ.
Det låter inte så jävla verkligt.
Du har ren desperate.
Ni har inga syra kolleger, ni bråkar aldrig, och det finns inga tulliga ögonblick.
Nu kanske jag får skit för detta, men jag säger det.
Jag håller med, men vad brinner ni mest för?
Idag välkomnar vi Charlotta Dahlqvist till podden Make Sweden Stronger.
Tjena Charlotta.
Hej Joel.
Kan du ge oss en liten recap på vem du är som människa?
Vi börjar inte snacka barndom, men vem är du?
Tung fråga att inleda med, men om man börjar med det jag gör och jobbar med så har jag varit i svenskt detaljhandel nu i 25 år i år.
Det är ganska länge tycker jag.
Jag har stretat på och började som så många andra inom fysisk handel och sen har jag klättrat hela vägen upp genom e-handel och även jobbat en del med återförsäljare handel och så vidare.
Till där jag är idag, så jag är en handelsperson kan man väl verkligen säga.
Och privat, då säger jag ingenting.
Exakt, det blir skitbra.
Vilka bolag har du jobbat på?
Jag var i Sverige chef för Vero Moda för butikskedjan.
Det var ett stort uppdrag och jag var väldigt ung.
Det var mitt första chefsuppdrag.
Jag hade inte ens varit butikschef innan.
Jag hade inte haft någon egentligen större ledare erfarenhet.
Så klöver jag på det uppdraget.
Det var ett uppdrag som var hälften egna butiker, hälften franchise.
Det var 96 butiker från norr till söder.
Det var ett väldigt stort uppdrag att ta sig an.
Men också väldigt roligt och jag hade ett väldigt bra team.
På något sätt gick det vägen i ena fall.
Vänta, innan du går vidare på den var det ditt första chefsuppdrag?
Ja, det var det.
Jag var jätteung.
Hur gick det, mötet med den som satt in dig på det, vad tänkte de då?
Jag vet faktiskt inte, men jag hade jobbat med Veromoda och de andra varumärkena i Bessel i koncernen några år innan, så jag var ganska varm i kläderna.
Jag jobbade då på utbildningssidan, så jag hade ganska bra koll på vad de kämpade med, vad de stod och vad de behövde göra, vilka problem och utmaningar som fanns.
Så det var kanske inte så svårt som det verkar, rent uppdragsmässigt men såklart ett jättejobb ledarskapsmässigt.
Jag upplevde i alla fall när jag var ung, att man ses ju inte riktigt som en chef eller ledare.
Om du ska komma in, hur gammal var du då när du fick det här uppdraget?
Jag tror att precis hade fyllt eller skulle fylla 28.
Ja, och så ska du in och bas över, och så har du 96 butiker.
Tog folk det på allvar eller?
Jag tror jag hade med mig en viss bondus från den här utbildningstiden.
Jag kände franchise-tagarna, jag kände butikscheferna och regioncheferna.
Så det var ju inte så svårt, utan det hade ju varit betydligt tuffare tror jag, om man hade kommit in som en no-buddy i det sammanhanget.
Men jag hade en viss kännedom redan så det blev lättare.
Men det är klart att själva ledarskapet, där fick jag verkligen gå på sunt förnuft och mycket diplomati.
Det var receptet.
Vad blev största chocken i den resan?
För någonstans gissade jag att du signade på där och tänkte, fan vad coolt liksom, det här är ball liksom.
Sedan vaknar man upp där två dagar innan man ska ut i jobbet och så tänker man, vad ska jag göra?
Det är ju utmanande på så vis att du behöver ju kanske egentligen ha två typer av ledarskap.
Du behöver ha ledarskapet du har utåt i organisationen och för butikerna och för cheferna och ledarna som driver den här verksamheten.
Men du behöver också ha ditt eget ledarskap inåt, ditt eget team och det kan vara två helt olika typer av ledarskap.
Det var ju kanske någonting som jag fick utveckla och träna på medan bollen var i rullning.
Hur menar du att det skilder sig åt?
Det är jag nyfiken på.
När man jobbar med butiksägare och framtjänsttagare och regionchefer och butikschefer, de är ju också chefer.
De har ju sina team och de har ju sina strategier och sina utmaningar.
Det handlar ju så otroligt mycket om att öbentligt möta dem där de är.
Men internt i vårt eget team så var vi kanske tvungna att springa väldigt fort.
Vi var tvungna att fatta snabba beslut.
Vi var tvungna att kanske gå tuffare fram med vissa bitar än vad vi egentligen kunde göra utåt.
Det skedde rätt mycket hårt arbete under motorhuven som de aldrig egentligen såg i vidrullade utkärran ur garaget.
Det var utmanande såklart för mig att förstå det och att greppa det och att ha mitt eget team, alltså inköpare, marknadsförare, merchandisers och så vidare, och sen jobba med franchise-tagarna.
För det är en mycket mer trög-rörlig organisation och mycket vidare och mer långsiktigt kanske.
Medan vi var tvungna att försöka göra skillnad här och nu på nästa inköp och nästa kampanj och nästa måste det synas att det blir förändring som gör saker och ting bättre för dem.
Så det var såklart utmanande att driva de två ledarskapen parallellt.
När du kom in i den där rollen, fick du någon hjälp med ledarskapet då eller blev du bara, här kör nu?
Ja men det var så på Vestcellen då, på den tiden, de kastade i poolen och nu får du simma gullet.
Lite så var det.
Jag och många med nej har ju lärt oss jättemycket genom det, det har varit väldigt mycket frihet under ansvar.
Men jag hade också ett väldigt bra team, och som också var väldigt säkra i sina sadlar, på sina arbetsområden och det hjälpte mig väldigt mycket.
Jag tror att det hade varit jättetufft om jag hade haft ett mycket mer junior team till exempel.
För då hade de behövt mig mycket mer i själva uppgiften så att säga.
Men det här var ju ett senior team och de var ju duktiga som det var.
De behövde ju inte tränas upp i hur en bra merchandisingguide ska se ut.
Det visste de.
Tycker du att vi är för snälla mot ledare och chefer idag?
Att de ska tränas upp och de ska få jobba överallt och de ska få prata ut med folk.
Är det där en bättre strategi att bara in i hetluften, kör på, här har du din team?
Nej, inte generellt.
Jag tycker att det är en ganska tuff ton mot väldigt många chefer idag å andra sidan och från andra hållet.
Det är någonting som jag tycker är problematiskt, därför att det skulle nog behöva vara så att det var lite snällare mot chefer generellt i kommunikationsklimatet.
Det är jättesvårt att vara chef idag och det ska man ha stor respekt för.
Vad är det som är knepigt att man förväntas fatta alla perspektiv?
Eller att man ska ha...
Nej men alltså, dels som jag brukar säga, att jag tror att det kommer bli svårt framåt i framtiden.
Det har börjat redan nu.
Dels för att alla får inte bli chefer.
Det är ju fortfarande väldigt få kvinnor som är chefer eller blir chefer eller släpps fram som chefer.
Det är ju bara fakta.
Det är ingenting som jag sitter här och bara säger.
Det är ju tyvärr så.
Det ser ut.
Vi har en väldigt svag statistik.
Men det gäller även personer som kommer från en annan bakgrund, kanske en svensk bakgrund och så vidare.
Alla får ju inte bli chefer idag.
Sen tror jag att i framtiden kommer alla inte att kunna ha chefer.
Därför att information och nya sätt att arbeta, kunskap och kompetens, man säger ju alltid att det är färskvara, men det är ju mer sant än någonsin.
Så du kommer kanske inte ha kunskap än att driva ett bolag i framtiden.
Det tror jag kommer att bli problematiskt, för att man hinner inte utbilda folk i den takten som det kanske behövs.
Som AI är väl ett sådant område.
Det kommer att bli jättebetydelsefullt.
Men chefer hinner inte med att uppdatera och utbildas.
Vi så kunniga kanske som de behöver vara för att kunna genomföra den utvecklingsdelen.
Man kommer inte hinna utbilda mellan chefer och så vidare.
Det kommer att bli svårt därför att det blir ett knowledge gap.
Det knowledge gapet hinner man inte fylla igen.
Man hamnar i otakt med tiden och tiden springer allt snabbare.
Så det är väl det att man kommer inte kunna vara chef kanske fullt ut hela vägen eller sitta så länge som man har gjort tidigare.
Sen tror jag också att alla kanske inte kommer att vilja vara chef därför att det är så hårt och så tufft klimat.
Du kan bli uthängd, du kan göra ett snedsteg och hamna på första sidan i expressen.
Det är inte ovanligt.
Det kanske du gör som väldigt ung eller oerfaren.
Du kan hängas ut i sociala medier, du kan straffas på olika sätt i ditt oerfarna ledarskap och chefskap.
Det tror jag att unga idag inte är duggintresserade av.
De är inte duggintresserade av att bli uthängda på sociala medier eller ansättas från olika mediala perspektiv.
Det finns räddslar att kliva upp i chefs roll.
Jag vill inte ta ansvaret här eller jag vill inte bli granskad eller ifrågasatt på det sättet.
Det är obehagligt och det är obehagligt.
Sen ska ju chefer alltid granskas och man ska verkligen vara noga med att utvärdera chefer för att de finns där av en anledning och man ska absolut inte tro att man är osynlig i den rollen.
Men det är tufft.
Det är ju chefskapet och ledarskapet framåt.
Det kommer bli problem.
Alla kan inte, alla får inte, alla vill inte.
Jag köper det.
Borde du?
Nu hamnar vi helt off-topic här, men jag tycker att det är en spännande fråga för jag kan uppleva att det här är, jag har liksom ingen statistik på detta, men jag kan ju uppleva när jag pratar med yngre personer att de har inte riktigt samma uppenbara där karriärs-steg-längtan som generationen över min hade en helt annan och de tyckte att vi inte hade det och sen så kommer nästa generation och de tycker vi, jag pratade med en kille som är 15 år yngre än mig och han var helt oförstående i vad vitsen med att bygga ett företag var.
Varför ska man göra det liksom?
Eller vad går du ut på?
Och för mig är det bara en inlärd grej, det vill jag ju.
Det är liksom bara en, det bara är så.
Och sen så kan jag uppleva att de kanske inte har samma, ska man säga, att man låter kommentarer rinna av sig eller att man blir lite känsligare kring vissa kommentarer, men framförallt kanske i verkliga livet.
De har en hårdare grej kring internet, eller en hårdare humor på ett visst sätt, men konflikter i verkligheten tar ganska hårt eller man tenderar att stänga av.
Kan man liksom hantera det som företag?
Så om du tar in unga personer ska man direkt börja såhär, ja nu ska vi öva på konflikter.
Ja, jag tror mer att det kanske är så att man på ett väldigt, med en liksom fast hand, men också en mjuk hand, får försöka förklara att såhär jobbar vi.
Det här är så vi gör i den här arbetsgruppen och det finns vissa principer som vi har och som gäller här och det kommer att vara så för alla.
Så länge du gör ditt absolut bästa och i förhållande till de här principerna så kommer det gå jättebra.
Det tror jag kan vara viktigt.
För det handlar väl kanske någonstans om att de har inte riktigt förstått vilka förväntningar som finns på dem helt enkelt.
Och jag tror att de vill bara göra bra ifrån sig men de förstår liksom inte att de har en förväntan att komma i tid.
Jag hade en anställd som inte kom till jobbet en gång för att det snöade.
Och det var bara så där.
Nej, nej det snöar så jag kommer inte in idag.
Nej, nej men de andra är ju här.
Jag har faktiskt haft samma situation.
Vi var ju inte på att hänga ut, det är en bra kollega.
Men det var faktiskt också snö.
Och så var vi på en grej och då var tåget inställt.
Men vi skulle ju mötas på ett bygge och lösa bygget.
Så det var ju liksom inget.
Vi var där och så går det liksom en timme och vi bara vad fan har hänt?
Så här sent är ju inte tåget.
Så ringde vi och då hade han åkt hem.
Jag bara, ringer du inte då?
Eller, nummer ett så ringer du väl och säger att det inte går.
Och nummer två så skiter jag väl ifall tåget är inställd och tar en taxi och så ringer jag och så får vi betala den.
Men liksom, du måste ju till bygget, det är ju bokat, vi är ju här.
Det var en väldigt lustig resen är väl inte det.
Skitsamma, vi bör inte fastna i...
Nej men det är ju lite...
Kul att det alltid är snön.
Så tror jag också att många unga liksom inte vill bossa.
Att det är lite känsligt.
Man vill liksom inte bossa över någon annan för att det anses som lite osjönt tror jag.
Att man har det lite bossiga beteendet.
Och det kan också vara en del i att man inte vill leda.
Det är lite alla ska med och alla är lika och det tror jag är jättebra.
Det är en sån otroligt bra grundsyn.
Men det gör också att man drar sig från att kliva fram och fatta besluten och käfa så att säga.
Det kan bli lite ämligt kanske tills man har fattat ett beslut i den här nya unga gruppen.
Nu har vi kommit en tredjedel på vägen av frågan nummer ett.
Ja, vad bra!
Det här går bra för oss.
Du hade varit på Vero Morda, vad hände sen?
Ja, sen började jag på eleven.
Det var jättebra för mig, därför att eleven var en väldigt tidig e-handel inom kosmetik.
Eleven på den tiden hade alla funktioner och arbetsumråden i princip in-house.
Så jag kunde gå runt där och säga, ja, vad gör du?
Ja, SCM säger du, SCM är jag.
Ja, vad är det?
Så kunde jag lära mig av de som kunde det där.
Det var en väldigt bra skola för mig, det var jättefriffigt.
Jag sparade enormt mycket tid på att lära mig av det teamet som fanns där.
Det var jättebra, för då lärde jag mig det.
Sedan har jag jobbat lite grann, kort sväng på klädmärket Boomerang, jobbat med återförsäljare och så vidare.
Men på Linum som är mitt senaste uppdrag som operativchef och som vd har jag varit de senaste åtta åren.
Men nu har du slutat där?
Nu har jag slutat där, precis.
Jag packar ihop de sista kartongerna här nu och lämnar till sommaren.
Det är för att det är nyägare som har tagit vid och ska driva Linum in i framtiden.
Det är jättespännande såklart.
Jag tänker att vi kanske får nämna att det är väldigt färskt.
Du skrev något inlägg här om jag stänger dörren eller något sånt där för sista.
Så det är bara några veckor gammalt.
Ja, precis.
Det är det.
Så det är väldigt färskt.
Men de har tillträtt att köra på här nu så det är spännande att följa från sidan av.
Men jag kliver av och ja, lämnar den här resan bakom mig.
Ja, jag tänker att vi kommer tillbaks lite till vad som händer nu eller hur tankarna går där.
Men om vi går in på Linum lite grann.
Jag tänker, jag har ju många lyssnare som är som mig, killar mellan 35 och 40.
Vi är kanske inte den primära kundgruppen här.
Vad är Linum för någonting?
Linum är specialiserat på hemtekstil och är sedan ett design-
och varumärke som har funnits sedan 1966.
Det är det som vi gör.
Vi tar fram produkterna själva, alltså allt från design.
Vi producerar det mesta i Indien hos producenter som har varit med redan.
Från början, från 60-talet vilket är fantastiskt.
Sen säljer vi framförallt i Europa.
Tyskland har varit den största marknaden och Sverige är också stor.
Men ja, framförallt ut i Europa.
Det är lite spännande med gamla varumärken, sen finns det äldre varumärken såklart, men det är intressant med gamla varumärken som vågar gå in på e-handel på något sätt och faktiskt driva den affären.
Så jag tänkte ändå att vi ska fastna där lite grann för att jag tycker det är spännande.
Först får jag veta hur det är att komma in på ett bolag som har en, för det är inget massivt bolag på det sättet.
Det är inte som att komma in på IKEA eller H&M utan det är ändå ett ganska tight team, men det är ändå en ganska lång historik.
Hur är det att komma in på ett bolag som har det arvet, och så ska man komma in och göra förändringar, men man blir på något sätt tvungen att respektera, det här är vad vi står för och det finns fem värderingar, rör det inte utanför det, det måste vara en rätt skum situation.
Ja men alltså fördelen med det, det är ju att alla kunder, eller i alla fall många kunder eller våra kunder, vet ju vilka vi är.
Och nackdelen är ju att alla kunder eller många kunder eller våra kunder, vet vilka vi är.
Så det är liksom både fördelen och nackdelen att man redan är etablerad och det är ett jättetufft och jättetunt arbete att etablera sig som varumärke och det har jag stor respekt för att komma som ny aktör och så ska man knuffa sig in på en marknad och göra sig ett namn och bygga upp en kundbas.
Och det är ju jättesvårt, det tar lång tid och krävande och mycket kraft och mycket testa och man känner kanske att man glider med dåligt glid i perioder och behöver valla om skydden är ett par tionde varv, det är tufft.
För oss har det också varit att våra kunder har haft mycket och stora förväntningar på det vi är och det varumärke vi är och vad vi ska leverera för typ av produkt och hur vi ska se ut och vad vi ska göra för mönster och vad vi ska sälja produkterna, alltså vilka priser vi ska ha och vad vi ska finnas på för marknader.
Så det har ju varit väldigt, väldigt mycket att lyssna in kunden och ge den vad den vill ha.
Det har ju inte funnits alls samma frihet att skissa från ett tomt papper.
Okej, så det är kunden som har varit den kontrollerande gränsen, det är liksom inte ägarna som har varit?
Nej, kunden.
Alltså i nästan varenda frågan skulle jag säga.
För ni gjorde ju en extrem sortimentsbegränsning, kan du inte ta mig igenom det och hur ni liksom samkörde det med, där kunde åsikterna liksom?
Ja men vi hade ju ett jättestortiment på nästan 5000 artiklar och det är ju liksom helt ohållbart sett till vår storlek.
Dessutom att sälja 5000 artiklar är ju oerhört komplext.
Vad är er storlek på den tiden när ni påbärde det arbetet?
Vad som har satt er i kontext?
Alltså du tänker ju omsättning.
Ja.
Ja men ungefär 20 miljoner liksom om året.
Och så hade ni 5000 fördufte, det är helt bizarrt.
Nej men alltså det var ju liksom jättetufft, det där kunde vi ju liksom inte hålla på med.
Så att vi fick nisha oss och ta ner sortimentet och vi tog ner sortimentet duktigt.
Alltså vi gick ju från 5000 artiklar till 500 på tre, och sålde ut, ska jag säga också, det lagret som fanns.
Och de artiklar vi hade, så det var liksom ingenting som kastades på sophögern, utan det gick ut till kund, vilket jag också är jättestolt över, liksom utifrån ett hållbarhetsperspektiv.
Men vi tog ner det till 500 artiklar och de artiklarna som blev kvar, det var ju linenskår.
Det vi alltid hade gjort, det som hade funnits i generationer, vi hade liksom producerat de här produkterna i decennier, alltså det var liksom inga surprises whatsoever.
Men vi blev mycket mycket bättre på att tajta ihop, liksom färgpaletten till exempel.
Ja, liksom försöka par ihop produkter så att det stämde mycket mycket bättre med, med att det blev ett sortiment.
Var det det man tittade?
Man tittade liksom inte på vad som säljer mest, utan man tittade på vad anser vi är framtiden för Linum, eller hur?
Hur gjorde man avvägningarna när det blev svårt?
Jag fattar att många av dem är liksom densamma, men ni måste ha haft några såhär av...
Det är ändå att ni drog ner sortimentet rätt kraftigt.
Ni måste ha haft rätt mycket avvägningar.
Ska vi behålla den eller inte?
Vad var det som avgjorde om den fick behållas eller inte?
Ja men till största del var det kunddatan som sa att det är de här produkterna som är de starkaste och det var också våra sina produkter i mångt och mycket.
Sen var det ju avvägningar på färg till exempel, där tyskarna var så otroligt sugna på att behålla lime i sortimentet.
Det är ingen svensk som har köpt det på 3000 år om någonsin.
Men det ville tyskarna ha och då fick ju lime vara med.
Den heter mosskrum hos oss men det är lime.
Jag fattar, ja.
Heter den lime i Tyskland?
Nej, det värre inte för mig.
Mossgrön där också.
Mossgrön, ja.
Men det är det vi kan säga, det är lime.
Vi förstår alla vad det är vi jobbar med här.
Nej men det är absolut inte en kommersiell färg för oss whatsoever.
Men eftersom de vill ha den så är den för stor för att ta bort.
Är den on brand?
Kanske inte.
Utifrån ett svenskt perspektiv så är den ju kanske inte det.
Men de vill ha den och den säljer bra där och då blir det så.
Hur utvecklades omsättningen under de åren och hur mycket lade sig kunder i när saker började försvinna?
Båda de frågorna tänker jag på.
Vi flyttade ju omsättning från återförsäljareledet till e-handeln.
Det var ett väldigt svårt och komplicerat arbete att flytta omsättning från en säljkanal till en annan.
Man kan ju inte göra det egentligen för bryst utan det måste ske stegvis.
Och e-handeln var väldigt tidig och omogen när det här arbetet påbörjades.
Den var ju inte en konverteringsmaskin på något sätt, det ska jag inte säga.
Hade den varit det så hade det varit lättare och gått snabbare.
Omsättningsmässigt tycker jag nog att det var ett steg fram och två steg bak ibland.
Och det hände mycket annat som påverkade omsättningen under den här perioden också.
Brexit till exempel, det var inte kul då förlorade vi en och en halv miljon över en natt.
Det var ju mycket sådana saker som man var också tvungen att parera.
Jag gillar att ni inte gjorde en grej samtidigt utan ni skulle göra flera grejer samtidigt.
Ja det var bara, det var på.
Allt, allt skulle vi.
Varför skulle ni flytta in allting i egen kanal?
Lina Määr är egentligen ett traditionellt grossvarumärke.
Det har varit stort på återförsäkta sidan och varit ett väldigt stort bolag en gång i tiden med flera dotterbolag ut i Europa och så vidare.
Men hade enorma problem med lönsamheten och affärsmodellen fungerade inte, de var inte up to date med samtiden, utan den hade föråldrats.
De avtal som bolaget hade var inte tillräckligt bra.
Man hade en föråldrad agent setup som inte riktigt levererade med samtiden.
Inte att de inte levererade, utan det var att det gick inte i takt med tiden.
Där behövde vi ställa om och bli ett mycket mer snabbfot att ett modernt konsumentvarumärke.
Det där behövde ske parallellt, nedmontering och flyttning, alltså flytta omsättning, och samtidigt bygga upp det här slutkunstvarumärket, Linum.
Det är ju flera stora uppdraget kan man egentligen säga.
Jag kan inte 11, jag vet inte vad det är för bolag riktigt, men vi är omborda vet jag ju.
Det är ett ganska stort mycket sitter och sen detta var ju en betydligt mindre operation.
Var det konstigt att göra så?
Plötsligt har du inget team runt omkring det som fattar allting och kan lösa allting, utan kanske du har kolleger, men jag menar det är inte samma setup riktigt.
Nej det är det inte, men Linum har varit väldigt komplext i sin lilla lilla kostym, utifrån affärsmodellen som då från början var det här grossbolaget som sånnde till återförsäljare ut i Europa.
Det kunde vara allt från stora möbelskedjor till små enskilda butiker i Antib till att bli ett ganska snabbt snurrande hjul där e-handeln står för den största andelen, ungefär 40% och sen 30% på återförsäljareledet och 30% på Amazon.
Det fungerade ju bra och syftet med det var ju att bolaget skulle bli lönsamt, annars hade vi inte gjort den här stora operationen.
Vad var det som fick dig att tacka ja till det uppdraget?
Det är ändå en lite annorlunda avstickare jämfört med tidigare bolags struktur.
Framförallt var det ju för att kontoret låg i city och jag ville hoppa ut i Nacka stranden.
Nej, jag skojar.
Det ska man inte underskatta.
Det säger mina killar igen.
Vad gillar ni mest med gymkompaniet?
Att det är nära och man får jobba hemma.
Ja precis.
Nej, det var ett väldigt svårt uppdrag fast i den här ganska lilla kontexten.
Sen är det också jättetroligt att jobba på varumärkesidan.
Det är jättekul att jobba för ett varumärke.
Det är en annan sak att jobba för en återförsäljare som Eleven till exempel.
Det är också ett varumärke, men de är en återförsäljare.
När man jobbar för ett varumärke så är det en helt annan uppgift att sätta det varumärket också hos kunden, tonaliteten, uttrycket, kundkontakten, dialogen, bildmaterialet och copyn.
Allt det här är en helt annan upplevelse att driva.
Det är en helt annan sak att driva än att vara en återförsäljare.
Även om man har sitt varumärke då också såklart.
Men inte riktigt på samma sätt, därför att du bygger din verksamhet runt de varumärkena du har i ditt stall.
Ja, jag köper det.
Det kan vara fascinerande.
Om vi går in på det här, du sa att ni hade lite föråldrade avtal och liknande, er agent-sutapp och liknande.
Jag kan inget om detta, men det har typ rullats på i 50 år.
Och så kommer du in och säger att du behöver förhandla om det här nu.
Vi behöver göra så här, hur var den dialogen?
Det var en del av kunderna och en del av agenterna sa att vi förstår det och vi kan inte hjälpa er för att vi inte har själva det nätverket som ni efterfrågar eller den kompetensen.
Så att vi förstår er, även om det är tråkigt och det kanske var någon som blev besviken och så där.
Men de flesta förstår ju att man behöver utvecklas.
Siffrorna talar ju sitt eget tydliga spåk så ofta.
Sen är jag nyfiken på själva försäljningen här.
För du gick in som vd för två år sedan?
Ja, precis.
Och varit i bolaget sen 2018.
När du gick in som vd var det ett av dina uttalade uppdrag att vi ska sälja bolaget.
Men nu vill du att du ger ordning bolaget för det?
Nej, det tycker jag nog inte att det var.
Vi ville ju gärna att Linum skulle komma in i ett nytt sammanhang.
Det var ju någonting som vi önskade skulle ske såklart.
Men vi hade också vårt uppdrag att hela tiden försöka stärka Linum och tänka även fortsatt långsiktigt.
Man måste ju alltid vara beredd på att en försäljning kanske inte blir av eller så.
Du får ju hela tiden jobba med de två parallella uppdragen.
Det tycker jag ändå att vi gjorde bra.
Det är ju inte sånt förrän det är sålt.
Nej exakt.
Du behöver ju ändå, och det ska man också komma ihåg, att det tar tid att sälja ett bolag.
Det är ju liksom ingenting man gör i en handvändning.
Det kan inte ta flera år liksom.
Och då måste du vara beredd på att du har en verklighet och liksom ett jobb att göra under tiden.
Och hur ska du i så fall prioritera där liksom?
Men fanns det liksom vissa krav från köpande, eller fanns det vissa önskemål från köpande, att vi skulle vilja att ni kan uppvisa detta, och så fick ni jobba mot det eller hur gör man för att liksom?
Nej, alltså det är också någonting som jag tycker att man ska vara liksom beredd på för att man för ju flera olika parallella dialoger med flera olika intressenter oftast.
Det är ju inte bara en utan det kan ju vara många som är i loopen.
Och de här köparna, eller intressenterna, de kanske är intresserade av olika delar av verksamheten, och de tycker att vissa saker där kan vara en kronjuvel och det de letar efter.
Och det kan ju vara till exempel att de redan driver flera lite liknande varumärken och så passar det här in.
Och så har man en grundset-up med personal och ekonomi och lager och så driver det och så är det lätt att placera in det här varumärket för att stärka upp den redan befintliga verksamheten.
Men det kan också vara att man till exempel är väldigt intresserad av linum som varumärka, att det man tycker är kul och spännande och potentialen ligger i det.
Det vill jag driva, det är kul.
Jag älskar hemtextil, jag älskar inredning.
Det här är någonting för mig att hålla på med.
Eller så kan det vara så att man är jätteintresserad av Amazon-affären därför att man själv har en produkt som man tror passar jättebra i det formatet men man har inte kunskapen inhouse.
Men då är den delen jätteintressant.
Olika kunder eller intressenter kan ju vara intresserade av olika saker i ens verksamhet och det får man vara beredd på också.
Att det kan hackas sönder och delas och det man själv kanske tycker är jättebra och man är stolt över det, det kanske de tycker är det där, det är inget där kommer vi lägga ner eller det där är inget för oss eller det där kan de behålla själva, det där vill de inte ha.
Man plockar i särbilen och slänger ut ratten och tar sin egen.
Men så kan det vara.
Och det får man bara köpa.
Jag köper det väldigt hårt.
Vi har ibland fått lite små propåer från bolag som, små företag som vi blir uppköpta.
De säljer in ett koncept, och här är, ja titta vad vi har byggt upp för e-handel.
Och så blir det så här, den hade inte vi tagit.
Vi är ju bara intresserade av era exklusivitetsavtal med vissa varumärken i så fall.
Det är det vi köper, det andra är liksom relativt oförsäkert.
Det kan ju låta lite drygt, men det är ju så, det funkar.
Det är så det funkar.
Jag bara tänker att man får fundera på vad köparen letar efter.
Jag tycker det är väl spännande.
Ja, och inte ha någon prestige i det tror jag.
Det är liksom att tycka att, där kom de och sa att det här inte var något att ha.
Det är ju ingenting att sitta och bli ledsen över.
Att de tycker att det inte var tillräckligt bra eller snyggt eller attraktivt.
Utan det är bara så det är.
Därför att de ser olika syften med ens verksamhet.
När folk snackar om ni kanal så har ni lyckats med rätt mycket om ni kanal.
Ni hade även en butik tidigare.
Mm, just det.
Och sen så ni säljer på, eller sålde, jag får hela tiden prata i past tense, det känns lite knepigt.
Men ni sålde på Amazon och ni var grossist, ni hade egen e-handel.
Om du skulle ta de fyra kanalerna, vad var liksom skönast med respektive kanal och vad var krångligast med respektive kanal om du skulle liksom ge råd till andra e-handlare?
Ja men de fyllde liksom lite olika funktion för oss i verksamheten i bolaget och det var därför vi hade den setupen.
Butiken hade vi, för att vi hade den typen av lokal där vi kunde ha butik på bottenmåningen, men egentligen så var väl liksom inte det en del av vår affärsmodell och vi satt ganska säkert i den digitala sadeln och det var ett ganska enkelt beslut att inte ta med butiken när vi flyttade ut från det kontoret och flyttade till den här adressen där vi sitter idag, eller satt idag, men det blir ju svart snart.
Jag får också prata liksom i dåtid men de andra tre behövde vi av olika skäl kan man väl säga, där e-handeln var liksom mamman eller the mother i hela vår verksamhet och det var ju den stora kommunikationsplattformen, vi drev varumärket väldigt starkt därifrån, vi drev ju all trafik och marknadsföring dit i princip, den var ju väldigt betydelsefull för hur linum uppfattades och sen så ersatte kan man säga Amazon återförsäljare affärerna ut i Europa, därför att vi hade ingen bra affär och ingen lönsamhet i den här lilla boden i Antib.
Det blev för dyrt att skicka två kvod federal dit varannan månad, så det ville vi inte hålla på med.
Och när vi stängde den typen av butiker och avtal och förhandlade om och så vidare, då flyttade kundens efterfrågan in på Amazons plattform.
Det gjorde att vi kunde växa på Amazon väldigt snabbt.
Många undrar vad det var vi egentligen gjorde, men vi hade ju redan etablerat oss i Europa.
Så kunden började leta efter oss på Amazon istället, därför att Amazon är så stort.
Man förstår ju inte riktigt det som svensk, men i Europa är ju Amazon väldigt stort.
Så var det och det blev lätt för oss att driva försäljningen den vägen istället.
Sen är det svårt att få lönsamhet på Amazon, men Amazon har varit väldigt bra för våra volymprodukter till exempel.
Den har bidragit till inköpen.
Så vi har behövt Amazon för att trycka volym på de varor som har varit absolut viktigast för oss att få till inköpen på.
Vi har egentligen bara sålt fem produkter på Amazon men i olika färger.
Så det har varit en väldigt tajt affär.
Och återförsäljare har varit jättebra också utifrån ett volymperspektiv men även utifrån ett kassaflödesperspektiv om jag ska vara helt ärlig.
Så det hade varit svårt att klara sig utan återförsäljare affären för att få en mycket mer stadig och stabil kassaflödesutveckling egentligen.
Så de har ju bidragit på olika sätt och det skulle ha varit väldigt svårt för oss att klara oss utan någon av dem.
Men skulle du rekommendera er andra att köra på ett sådant spittat fokus?
Jag skulle nog vara försiktig att komma med rekommendationer till andra utan att veta mer om man har vad sortiment och produkter.
Amazon passar absolut inte alla bolag.
Du kan inte sälja allt på Amazon därför att det är så mått-
och viktbaserat.
Du måste ha lätta produkter för att lyckas på Amazon, annars blir det liksom en lönsamhetskrasch.
Hela deras affär är egentligen en logistik.
Det är det, det sitter.
Och egentligen inte så mycket annat.
Så det ska man nog akta sig för, att tänka att Amazon är absolut för oss.
För det är inte alls säkert att det är.
Och att det försäljare tar också mycket tid.
Du måste ju såklart finnas där för dem.
Och liksom hjälpa dem, bistå dem.
Och hantera deras orders, frågor och claims.
Så det kanske inte heller är för alla.
Man har inte de resurser att lägga helt enkelt.
Men har man det så är det jättebra.
Det har varit jättebra för oss.
Och också ett väldigt bra sätt att få ut linum genom stora och skickliga återförsäljare.
Du snackade lite kort där om varumärke.
Min fördom någonstans är att Amazon är ju inte varumärkesboosten, utan det är snarare här säljer vi volym som du säger.
Har det varit en konflikt eller har det varit, det är på de marknaderna så det spelar ingen roll och vi säljer själva så vi kan kontrollera hur?
Exakt så har det varit.
Att vi säljer själva, vi kan kontrollera, vi har byggt våra egna shoppar på Amazon och de ser ut nästan exakt som vår egen e-handel.
Så det har varit ganska stor igenkänning tror jag för den kunden som har rört sig mellan Amazon och vår egen e-handel.
Och vi kunde också se ett ganska stort samband mellan egen e-handel och Amazon.
Vi kunde inte mäta det såklart och vara helt säkra men absolut att vi kunde se att det ena drog det andra.
Nu när du har stängt över den här då.
Har du redan gått vidare eller kommer du göra det här klassiska, du vet, ta ett halvår och ta sommar eller hur går tankarna?
Jag vet inte.
Alltså jag tänker att om det skulle komma någon till mig och bara du, jag sitter riktigt i skiten med mitt bolag.
Då hade du tyckt att det var kul.
Då bara, åh, hur mycket i skiten sitter det hade jag sagt.
Så jag bara, ja det här är kul.
Då hade jag tvittat, då hade jag nog kunnat kliva på i mån.
För att jag är så uppdragsstyrd, ser att det finns ett roligt uppdrag på bordet, då hoppar jag på.
Men blir det inte så, så blir det inte så.
Då är det ju så, då tar jag en lång sommar.
Jag tycker att många som har varit i bolag länge, går konsultspåret sen och så går man in i den.
Man börjar sälja in uppdrag och man börjar sälja in olika.
Är det att gå tankarna i den eller tänker du att nu ska jag hoppa in i ett företag igen?
Du har ändå varit några år i det här linum, behöver man ladda om tankarna?
Nej, alltså...
Skit i det.
Ja men precis, nej det var igår, nej jag vet inte, nej jag ska.
Men jag är ju klar med det här uppdraget i och med att det är en ny ägare, och då går man ju i mål.
Det är oerhört frustrerande att sitta på ett uppdrag som man inte kommer i mål med och behöver lämna och sedan gräma sig och känna att jag blev inte klar eller att jag borde ha gjort det där också eller att det där hamnade vi inte med.
Det är ju inte en sån rolig känsla.
Det kan ju vara så att man känner det också med sitt team och att vi blev inte färdiga här och jag var tvungen att lämna mitt i och det blev stökigt.
Men så har det ju inte varit.
Vi är ju klara, vi är ju jättenöjda och stolta och tycker att det här har varit en fantastisk resa.
Så vi går ut i solkenet liksom.
Ja men faget, jag gillar det.
Charlotta, oavsett vad det blir så stort lycka till framöver och stort tack för att vara med och delade resan och alla tankar.
Tack ska du ha, vad kul det var.
Nummer ett så ringer det väl och säger att det inte går.
Och nummer två så skiter jag väl ifall tåget är inställd och tar en taxi och ring mig och så får vi betala den.
Men liksom, du måste ju till bygget, det är ju bokat vi är ju här.